how do you fight with a dog yeah on
screen well we did baby steps because
they were so strong
so that's me that looks insane we did
that for real I think Brad needed a
break after the phone he was kind of
done smashing my head
we were in motion capture suits we had a
malfunction something happened I went
head first and I scorpioned my feet went
over oh my gosh
you did this done everything had to go
right and the way they cut it up was
just talk about cutting things up and
making me really angry
thanks to heel for sponsoring this video
what's up everybody Jordan here and we
have some bad ass women on the couch
today but before we get into Amy and
Kimberly I'm here to talk to you about
our sponsor appeal do you know my
biggest problem nowadays is time I don't
have time for those after workout
smoothies for that after workout
breakfast one of the biggest things that
people lack in their daily diet is
protein but when it's super easy to
drink like this it's 22 grams right off
the bat one of my favorite things is
that it's 100 vegan and they're using
pea protein it contains 27 essential
vitamins and minerals they're
plant-based and gluten-free it's a super
easy source of fiber and they're made
with all natural ingredients they have
eight different flavors and some of my
favorite flavors are bananas berries
cinnamon roll and iced coffee I
absolutely love coffee to the iced
coffee caramel is my favorite I think
it's time that you go find out for
yourself if you click the link in the
description below you can get started
with your own package of ready to drink
heel it even comes with a guide and a
t-shirt to get you started it thanks to
heal for sponsoring this video and thank
you guys so much for listening now let's
get into step one with react
what's up everyone so we are back with
another episode of stunt women react I'm
so happy to be here with one of the most
incredible stunt women in the industry
Kimberly Shannon Murphy of course this
guy over here you know you've been
working for a long time in the days you
have a bunch of experience can you tell
us a little bit about your work and what
you've been been up to I started about
18 years ago My Super Ex-Girlfriend was
my first film doubling for Uma Thurman
at that time we actually mailed resumes
and had shops to coordinators and so I
mailed mine in and George Aguilar called
me a week later and said he was doing
this movie My Super Ex-Girlfriend and he
needed a double for Uma and he needed
someone who was really comfortable on
wires which is pretty much what I was
performing at the time and I did like a
two-week sort of audition I guess you
would say just so they could see how I
move and then she had the final say on
whether I got the job or not my career
just sort of took off and stayed with
her for a while and met Cameron Diaz and
stayed with her then here I am that's
awesome so we have a lot of really
amazing Clips to show today and you know
there's one I just I really want to just
jump in on it right away and it's the
brutal ending fight scene from Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood yeah so good
we rehearsed this scene for three months
wow oh wow the reason being was because
of the dogs
had you worked with dogs before I've
never done anything like not pit bulls
we actually rehearse four or three
months in the space with the dogs and we
didn't really we had an idea of what the
scene was going to be but Quentin hadn't
really decided who was going to do what
when he's into the scene is when he sort
of decides what is exactly going to
happen in the scene so we all train with
the dog so I did bites and I did all the
things so that yeah if he was to say
okay actually I think we're gonna have
Kim you know the dog go to Kim we were
all ready for that how do you fight with
a dog yeah on screen well we did baby
steps and so first we just learned to
kind of tug with the dogs you know with
a tug toy so we had three pimples one
was Brad's that we didn't do anything
with because it was his dog that he
worked with throughout the whole movie
so that dog was never supposed to ever
be around attacks see attacks or
anything for obvious reasons because it
was his dog that dog had a double that
did small not so violent attacks that we
used to kind of start doing things with
in the beginning there's a crotch bite
so we used the more Tamer dog to start
doing it with and then sir which is the
really violent dog which is who we did
all of the attacks with he's the one
who's in all of these scenes we we
eventually did it just with him but it
was a gradual process which is why we
rehearsed it for so long we would put
music on like we would add all these
elements into the scene so the dogs
would get used to it then we would put
like a mask on so they would get used to
seeing us with blood on her face and
then we would do it with the lights off
so it was like all of these little
things we were doing to add into the
scene on a daily basis so that when we
got into it the dogs weren't overwhelmed
or confused or all of a sudden the
lights were off and the music was
playing in blood everywhere and people
are screaming so we had to introduce
that to them slowly so that they
wouldn't freak out because once they
were attacking you if they get
distracted and come off of you they
could go somewhere else we had other
protection but mainly you're protected
in the area that they're attacking so
you never want them to come off and go
to another part of your body or to
somebody else in the room if the dog
came off of somebody
that we all just stopped and didn't move
and let the trainers come in and deal
with them and I assume everything went
well yes okay good it's not one issue
wonderful yeah the dog is playing as far
as the dog is concerned but you do not
want to ever get bit by a pitbull I will
tell you that right now we had almost
like cast like things that we put over
our arms and I would still come home
with bruises and bumps and blood because
they were so strong and I literally had
the dog drag me across the room but the
trainers were so good and could get the
dog off Us in two seconds and it was so
well done and rehearsed and prepared and
everyone did an amazing job
and then we did this for real so that's
me that looks insane and we did that for
real okay so ouch when you say for real
was there padding like I think that's
that looks like now okay and then that's
me when he throws her away that's me
yeah
okay first of all did you have a
headache and second of all what things
were padded and and how did you cheat
all of this the phone was you know it
was a rotary phone so the two things
that come out of that type of phone that
was foam everything else was real and
scored so the inside of the phone was
stripped and they put a foam on the
inside of the phone but the outside of
the phone was the outside of the phone
so the sound that you hear
[Music]
is actually real did you have any sort
of like padding um on your wig or were
you just hitting your forehead I was
hitting my head is this a situation
where Brad Pitt's just kind of putting
his hand on your hair and you're
actually doing all the driving motion we
did a little bit of both did your neck
hurt like how how was it more vicious
than it felt or a little bit well he
does some we had so much blood on us so
you you know it wasn't until we wrapped
that night that I you know could tell
but you know I mean I've had so many
concussions and so many things that I'm
very aware of what you know I was fine
but I knew that I was gonna have a bump
on my head and I mean obviously so this
is a situation where you're going in
it's this is kind of like a ascended
moment right where it's just like you're
gonna smack your face into this phone
and you're gonna do it five takes and
you're not gonna be it you're not
cheating at all a lot of people want to
like smack their heads they do kind of
like this right yeah of shoulder
involved if you see my hands are
completely free I didn't use my hands at
all there was no like bracing myself but
yeah we did it the glass was glass so
that's real glass breaking right it was
candy glass yeah how many times did you
do the the glass probably four he wanted
it really specific you see I I hit him
right in the crotch the second one
he was very specific about wanting that
and same thing like with the glass
poster is that like are you once again
are you are you driving yourself there
or is like kind of a combination of you
and Brad that was not Brad that was Zach
well as a stun person yes that did that
with me I think Brad needed a break
after the phone he was kind of done
smashing my head so I did that with it I
did that with his stunt double and it
was the same thing yeah just smashing
into the glass I mean it's candy so it's
and then they put a film over it which
is why it doesn't come out candy glass
is still sharp right oh you can get
stitches yeah yeah I've gotten stitches
from candy glass but because it had a
film over it it's kind of hard to if you
go through it and you land on it it's
quite it's
tomorrow we are releasing a
groundbreaking short it's called anime
Rock Paper Scissors Shoot
you will not want to miss it
have you taken heart injury many of your
stunts I imagine on my second second
movie I cut my face pretty bad going out
of a second story window
so it's this scene when the zombies got
the one but they're CG so they had you
do the stunt for real oh yeah so we were
in motion capture suits but we did all
of the stunts for real so they're
filming the actual shot for the movie
and you're in the position of where the
zombie would be yeah this is
this is very intelligent like that
so we were on a descender and there were
three of us coming out you can see
there's two people Will's double another
creature and then me that I'm the last
one as you can see my face it's like
very high because it's like the second
take but I'm like don't hit your face
there's descender and decelerator and
they both kind of act and do the same
thing every rigor comes in with their
own gear and their own equipment and um
now we have winches well we've had
winches for a long time which is what
basically flies us all over the place
and stuff like that but not a lot of
people know how to run them it just
depends on who you have on your show and
what kind of equipment they like to work
with and how they want to run things so
but my descender on the first take
didn't they're supposed to stop you
above the floor about five feet so it
kind of is like a little jolt so you
don't hit the ground we had a
malfunction something happened and I
went face first into as you see like the
glass falls on the floor we were on big
mats as well thank God and yeah I just
smashed my face so in your first take
you basically just went I went head
first and I scorpioned my feet went over
oh my gosh I'm surprised they didn't use
that take it yeah it was like yeah I
have a personal philosophy of any time
we're filming a stunt if like the hit
becomes real that's the take you have to
use and you alter the sequence to make
it work like out of respect right yeah
yeah
it's like that's why you're filming
stunts in a way it's like yeah getting
that physicality and when it becomes
hyper real it's like roll with it it
doesn't get better yeah yeah it's true
you gotta respect the sacrifice that the
performer just made there was a stunt in
here where I get snared so I get
ratcheted from my ankle
that's me inside the bag yeah yeah
oh man you know which they wound up like
obviously sieging a creature in there so
it really looking back I'm like why am I
in that black bag when you can't even
tell it like there's a human in there
and so did you have a harness on you
were picked it was ratcheted from my
ankle oh that was the ankle so like I
just stepped out and then the ratchet
swung me up from my ankle and you hit
the car and it swung up I hit a few cars
yeah ouch so either your hand you're
being hand pulled which is actually
something hand pulling you and usually
they'll stand on like a ladder sometimes
there's two of them standing on a ladder
holding the other side of your rope and
they literally jump off the ladder and
yank you and that's a hand pull or you
can be on a ratchet which is basically
like air and they push a button and it
just Yanks the crap out of you which
gives you more it's more of a dramatic
kind of yank than a hand pull so it
depends how far you're going how gnarly
they want it to look like what the
purpose of it is and then they'll decide
what they're going to use basically and
this was a wrap this is a ratchet yeah
you know with that said we take a
certain risk doing what we do and no
one's out to hurt anybody and we all
especially when you're doing a big
action film you have the best of the
best people working on it things
malfunction and things happen and you
know that's part of the risk we take in
our job obviously you all know you
should subscribe at this point if you
haven't subscribed I don't know what
you're doing because we're here with
awesome people all the time doing
awesome things why would you not
subscribe just subscribe please thank
you
right was an interesting we did a cool
stunt to break down actually that was
actually Netflix's first feature film
that they did I doubled Lucy Fry and we
did this done talk about cutting things
up and making me really angry
[Music]
you can see me rehearsing it and then
you can see how what they actually put
in the film we shot it with six cameras
I did it 22 times why you have six
cameras you don't need to do it 22 times
and it was like one of those things so
it was the stunt was we're in this gas
station the ceilings are 12 feet high
this car comes like crashing through the
glass and she basically jumps over the
car goes upside down over the car grabs
the gun behind her and does a flip so I
had
four people on my line and everybody was
doing something different so I was in a
gooch wrap which is what we call it
which is when the wire they put it going
around you this way which just helps you
navigate you to flip and that's the girl
technically it's Michael again on the
other side but there's supposed to be a
car under me right so clearly I'm not
high enough to clear a car but the
ceilings were so low in the gas station
that we had to it was really tricky to
just figure out how I basically had
three feet in between the ceiling and
the hood of the car it was just kind of
one of those things where everything had
to go right because everyone was pulling
like one person was Lifting me off the
ground another person was flipping me
over and another person was helping me
do the back flip so actually by take
three I'm like very good yeah it's kind
of one of those really sketchy things
and the way they cut it up was just you
couldn't even see that we actually even
did the Sun and that's why we bummer the
rehearsals
so that we have something to show for
all of our bruises and concussions yeah
yeah they're missing the like the length
of your body and the arc which is
beautiful like yeah that's the part that
they kind when they kind of came around
I feel like it lost it a little bit do
you know what I mean yeah yeah it just
looks like you're doing this
yeah yeah it looks like I kind of been
hanging there and then just dropped out
yeah exactly filmmaking is one of those
tricky things where you're working with
a huge team at like you could bring the
best your best a game if somebody else
doesn't your work doesn't shine yeah
it's really tough it can be really
disheartening sometimes yeah I've
learned not to take it personally
because in the beginning I was like I
was so amazing what I did and they
didn't and now I'm just like whatever I
got the paycheck on them
got the paycheck and you film The
Rehearsal yeah exactly there's so much
out there I can't watch all the movies I
can't watch all the TV shows I can't
keep track of all the six stunts please
leave a comment below with a sick stunt
from anything that's come out in the
past five years that we may not have
seen before you said you've been in the
industry for 18 years now have you seen
a difference in like being a part of
stunts back then to now are there more
safety precautions you know there's more
CG elements like what's kind of the the
difference between them when I started
you kind of did everything everyone did
everything you know you could ride a
horse you know we did all the things now
it's it's fights became kind of a
separate thing it's a more specialized
now especially with the fights I feel
like it's it's more of a separate entity
and with the John Wicks and everything
that I've kind of taken off it's kind of
taken a life of its own in that sense
and that is the biggest shift that I
feel like I've seen happen from the time
I started but are pads better now like
do you feel like more safety precautions
have been introduced or is it all very
similar I like keep my pads from like
they don't make them like they use oh
you have the good pets like the good
pads that you pull out and you're like
you need to sew that like
and I think that people have tried to
start making them more woman friendly
where they're a little bit more low
profile yes you know women's performers
have to deal with the fact that their
characters oftentimes are showing more
skin are wearing tighter costumes and
you can't deal with pads as easily so
you're just going out there you're
taking these hits with nothing to
protect you you know a guy shows up he's
got his full armor kit on you know has
that awareness shaped costumes or
character designed at all in this like
day and age or do you find that you're
still doing just as many stunts having
to be like well tank top and shorts
let's go yes if you're on a film where
the actress is really conscious of that
she's doing a lot of stunts and she's
being protective of her double that I
have seen be something that will change
things like make sure she's in make sure
we're in a long sleeve for this or make
sure we're wearing pants for this so
that we can Pat up and be you know have
more protection for us yeah okay this
amazing episode has finally come to an
end it's been incredible getting to know
some of the like stories and behind the
scenes stunts and really diving into the
history of all the incredible things
you've done I'm excited to see what you
do next you know Kimberly where can we
find your stuff if you wanted to follow
you more you could follow me on
Instagram I can really Shannon Murphy
stunts yeah and feel free to DM me or
anything about if you're interested in
getting in the business I'm always very
open to helping people as much as I can
so yeah good luck with those 800 DMs I
know right
well thank you so much so long everybody
see you for tomorrow's video on Sunday